c'était quand j'étais sous la douche
qu'il est venu il a fait ses premiers
attouchements là quand j'avais 6 ans
[Musique]
e
ça a commencé quand j'avais 6 ans donc
monsieur qui est voulait créer son club
de foot
donc il est venu dans la boulangerie
demandeurs et par an pour des sponsors
etc où on peut accepter qu'ils venaient
de monter sa boulangerie aussi ça me
faisait un peu de pub donc oui oui que
je viens dans cette association là puis
de fil en aiguille lui la fumette
l'emprise et prendre la confiance de mes
parents ensuite il est venu vers des
enfants quoi et vers m'en fallait que je
les écoute fallait que je fasse ce
qu'ils me disent pour aller loin dans le
foot parce que quand on est petit on
rêve d'aller loin dans le foot quoi à
force j'en avais marre de deux de ses de
ces violences
donc du coup ben je faisais plus rien je
me laissais faire quand il venait
c'était limite je savais ce qui
m'attendait donc donc je faisais je
faisais ce qu'il voulait vite pour peut
avoir mal et après moi j'ai eu la
naissance de mon petit frère et ça a été
vraiment là le déclic pour moi parce que
quand j'ai eu un petit frère sur ses
genoux je me suis dit ce qu'il a
vraiment il fera parti frère ça c'est
hors de question
donc je lui tire mes parents là ils sont
venus de suite je leur ai tout raconté
ils m'ont cru aussi de suite ce qui m'a
beaucoup aidé pour la suite j'aurais dit
les détails les plus par exemple lysekil
monter dans la chambre pour vous faire
mes devoirs et excusé d'un an leur fille
venait d'un match enfin tous les ans les
devoirs de maths et à chaque fois je
vais faire maths c'était la matière où
j'étais le plus nul qu à chaque fois
donc c'est celui c'est peut-être un
détail tout comme pour moi c'est un truc
qui aurait pu mettre une alerte quoi
déjà on est parti porter plainte
là on est tombé sur une gendarme
une policière vraiment
un rendement bien elle a pris le temps
d'écouter elle a pris le temps d'écouter
tous les petits détails que j'avais à
lui dire et quand on voit qu'on est pas
la seule victime qui a plusieurs
plusieurs enfants qui ont subi le même
truc commente par le même agresseur
c'est triste à dire mais ça fait un
petit soulagement parce qu'on se dit
vraiment il s'est pas nous le problème
parce qu'on est petit on se dit c'est
peut-être nos problèmes peut-être que
peut-être qu'on le mérite finalement
donc qui n'ont en fait on mérite rien du
tout et il faut vraiment fermé de tous
ces gens là et et parler le plus qu'on
peut à à nos enfants ou à tous les
enfants on pas enfin revenant qu'un
dialogue
si j'ai un conseil à donner aux victimes
qui sont en train de subir ça ou qui ont
subi ça qui ne sait pas parler il faut
pas voir un faux faux faux pareil faut
vider son sac tout simplement ça peut
faire du bien de temps en temps si
jamais on peut tomber sur une bonne
oreille bons conseils et sur qui as tu
eu peur de ne pas être cru mais après
tout on est dans une bulle déjà où
personne n'ose en temps et personne ne
voit donc un moment donné on peut se
lancer et se dire les couteaux pire des
cas serait pas cru au moins j'aurais
parlé et on aura entendu